when you think about the word
competition what does that mean to you i
think if competition is people um
reaching their highest potential they
have a potential they have the potential
to reach to reach their highest
potential when competition comes
competition is always good because it
helps you not to give in under the
slightest struggle in life
because life is going to life is going
to give everybody a bad hand no one's
going to leave here
um without being tried in life wow and
you have to be you know you're gonna
have to take it like what they say um
adversity make the strong stronger the
weak weaker
so so to you competition is inevitable
you can't avoid competition
right this minute
i'm competing with my wife
write this man i'm competing with my
wife if i'm gonna get home early enough
or not
but everything to you in life you see it
as a competition
everything has to be competition is
great it builds character and it gives
you backbone you don't have to give in
as i was saying earlier and the
slightest struggle some people like
nowadays it's like um everybody's um
believed that someone should give them
something yeah everybody nobody wants to
work now
anybody but special kids to have wealthy
parents like myself they don't most of
them don't want to do what they should
do
so how do you deal with that
then we're going to take then we gotta
go to trust funds
you gotta go to the truck if you don't
do this you don't get this
[Laughter]
right if you don't do this you won't get
this does it work oh it worked for
century
that's got to be a counter that's what
competition is all about
someone has to be number one once they
have a letter like everybody in the
family everybody in their family know
who's the strongest one in the family
who's the matriarch even if they're
older they can kick his ass they know
he's the boss and she's the boss
right
that doesn't have nothing to do with
strengthening being big they know who
the boss is they know who can run the
house they know who the us know it's not
the boss he distinguished himself or she
distinguished himself
out of all of us that's why we know
they're the boss even though we're older
than them
[Music]
why why do you think so many people
today don't like competition they're
almost like either sensitive to it or
they say it's not a good thing like why
do you think that's happening
i don't know i just don't know people
believe um
entitlement that's the word i was
looking for
a lot of people entitlement some of my
kids too they're entitled
they think their bank account should be
full because yours is though
that's just what they think you know i
did this all this for them but they have
to they have to match me you know maybe
you're making 200 bucks
you got 200 bucks a month whatever you
have i'll match that but i'm not gonna
give you something that you never worked
for you don't know exactly he don't know
the cause of the struggle for it
so without him knowing the struggle for
it he'll give it up very easily so if
you like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]